Do you watch those movies and shake
your head? I like him. I just, yeah,
I like science fiction, you know? Right.
You know, so yeah. I don't sit there.
I grew up with star wars. That was
my, when I was nine years older son.
Finances just don't, yeah,
I'm not having this. I did,
I did a an igert with Neil the grass,
not an argument but a debate with him
about lightsabers ones cause I claimed
that they're physically the in
principle there possible. Um,
and he was trying to say that they aren't,
but they are what did have to loop back
around cause the light's not continuing
to like the fact that it goes to
a certain distance and pauses.
We'd have to have a mirror
or something, I guess. Yeah.
Something that's going to be the end of
it. Right. That's true. So it wouldn't,
it'd be a different kind
of lights out there.
The only point I was
making is that photons,
particles of light can
bounce off each other.
So we see that in really high energy
experiments in parcel accelerators.
We can collide photons together.
So my point was a bit of a pedantic
physicist one but he's, cause he,
it is true that it light can bounce off.
It can hit light but very,
very high energy.
But when they press that button
to a certain distance, I wasn't,
that's engineering. I agree with you.
I agree with you. The distance thing,
I agree mass to it. Right. So
as you're swinging it around,
you wouldn't have the
leverage of a long thing.
So why not make it really long? Cause it
wouldn't be difficult to swing around.
Like you get stabbed someone with a
light saber a mile away. That's true.
Right. That's just to laser and it,
yes. Like why, why make it so short?
You have to swing, you got to be
close to hitting a person with it.
It's a silly silly design.
You are picking holes correctly
in the engineering. Part of my,
the only point I was
making is that physics is,
that we showing is quite interested in,
is like can bounce off light.
So,
but it would have to do,
it would have to be something that causes
it to stop at the very end. Yeah, yeah,
yeah. Which would be, you're
right, it have a mirror it,
but he wouldn't look cool with it if
there was no kind of thing within,
which drives me crazy about star
wars is not the light sabers.
It's the lasers. When they're shooting
the guns. I'm like, why can I see that?
Well I can't see bullets. Yeah. This is
supposed to be way faster than a bullet.
Like easy to see this cause
it's like George, you can duck,
you can get out of the way. Those
things, they really slow. So angry.
I feel like this is so dumb.
I could go warp speed in this Millennium
Falcon and travel the speed of light,
but for whatever reason,
these lasers are so slow that you
could duck out of the way of them.
That's so dumb. And he's not only
star wars is, it's everything.
Every single film does that.
Yeah. Yeah. Why we slightly,
it's like films, like also I worked
on one of these films years ago.
Sunshine Klove underappreciated.
Moving. Yeah, I think so.
I think brilliant film. But in that,
so they asked me or Danny said,
I want to do it right.
So do the spacecraft without any sand.
So when he's traveling through
space, there'll be silent
and it looks shit in it.
Just that when you watch,
yeah,
it's the same way when you try and fill
master naughts and you and they're in
zero g and they always move slowly.
It's like why, you know, you're right.
You're right. You'd be able to move very
fast as you want, but it looks silly.
So this kind of, uh, uh,
I suppose it's what audiences
had got yeast to over the
years. And so in the end,
you have a best friend has best
apart from 2001 which didn't do it.
Yeah.
Silent in 2001 well,
Kubrick was a stickler
for science and for you,
he was apparently he would do complex
mathematics in his spare time.
What fascinating guy. That must have
been. Yeah, I read that they just, um,
someone just found an interview,
didn't idea the day where he explained
the ending of 2001 I didn't say that.
Yeah, I saw it yesterday
actually, and it was,
it was kind of a really simple
version of it. He just said, well,
the sea for intelligent beings
take him in and put him in a zoo,
could basically and watch him grow old
and then send him back to the earth as a
super being,
but that's it.
That's the worst explanation at
the end of 2001 I've ever heard,
but he was key bricks. That's what cubic
said, so that he falls into the monolith.
Yet they just put them in this room,
which is kind of a bad version of a
French chateau or something watching grow
old and then send him out to the
earth as a super being. Wow. Okay.
That was Kubrick's. Yeah,
Persian. I strange. It's a,
it's a, it's a weird genre, right,
because sometimes people get things right,
like didn't hg wells predict a,
a significant amount of scientific
inventions in the future?
Well, there was these, I mean
it depends which one doesn't it?
There was a moon one wasn't there.
He did an agenda to the moon.
I mean he's time machine is not able
to do that really worked out yet.
But yeah, I think it's, I
always liked science fiction.
I like Arthur C. Clarke a lot. You know,
cause I, I think it is, you're right,
it's is a,
a form that you can let your imagination
wander and address things with that
restriction. I think, did you like
the alien series? I loved it. Yeah.
So I leave when I was, uh,
I, when I was at school,
he's nine 79 and we had a school
film club in the Seventies.
They weren't like they are now,
you know.
So the first films they
put on the three films,
I was 11 and it was alien apocalypse
now in life of Brian. Wow. Which I,
so that was my introduction to, to cinema,
how well those are three great choices,
but I feel like really Scott's original
alien is probably one of the greatest
horror science fiction movies of all time.
And one of my all time favorite movies.
But I really like the newer ones as well.
Like I like promethium and I really
liked covenant the, the last one. Yeah.
From atheists. I don't know. I,
yeah, it's not the best one. Oh look,
they're like what they're
trying to do with it. The,
the whole idea of what the engineers
coming back in time and that's it.
That's why I was disappointed with it.
Cause I thought the up the opening is
brilliant and I thought this is just going
to be brilliant.
Right.
And then I thought it just lost its way
and it was a disappointment because it
could have been so brilliant.
Yes, I agree with you. Yeah.
The beginning was fantastic, but I
think covenant was more, more exciting.
And what's also preposterous, like
if you went to another planet, I,
the last thing you'd be doing is
just breathing in the air. Right?
I mean we'd have to be really cool
if there was a life on the planet,
we'd have to be really careful.
A not to contaminate but be not
to be contaminated. Right. Yeah.
I mean, yeah. There's
also, I mean, you know,
the other thing is science
fiction films is gravity.
Cause you always give me an alien.
You always just say the spaceships
got gravity. There's again,
there's only 2001 right where
everybody floats around. Yeah.
Because all has a spinning thing.
The spaceship has gravity,
and then when you land, the gravity is
exactly like earth. Yeah. Perfect. Yeah.
But it's, you know, it's
ridiculous. Yeah. I mean,
with what are the odds that you would
find a planet that is exactly like,
even if a planet was one and a
half times the size of earth,
it would have far more
gravity. Right. And that's,
that's really common for a planet to be
like, just a little bit bigger. Yeah.
And then we'd be like, fuck
everywhere it'd be walking. We'd be,
we'd be getting crushed. Right.
I agree with you. Yeah. Well,
I suppose that's not the point.
It's about ideas, isn't it? Science.